as he arrives at Buckingham Palace and  come round the Queen Victoria Memorial  he will sweep across the forecourt into  the quadrangle behind and off to the  Kings door which is on the right of the  square inside the centre of the palace  so having crossed over through the North  Center gate  and over to the Kings door which we can  just see at the top of our shot with its  glass roof just to keep the worst of the  weather eyes away and there's a footman  there waiting for the Prime Minister's  car door  behind is the state entrance where later  on all the ministers chosen by the new  prime minister in this new  administration where all the new  ministers he sends will go to see the  Queen and receive their seals of office  the commander is welcoming the Prime  Minister mrs. Cameron and will lead them  into the palace straight up the Kings  stairs